Sort of,
um,
it's,
something's just take a lot of time to sort of get used to and other things sort
of wants.
It's,
it's there.
You kind of used to it in a second.
There's the example earlier this week,
he was driving a,
um,
uh,
a Tesla on,
on autopilot and um,
as driving it for five minutes and then already you're kind of doing your emails
and then when you take it off,
it just feels like you're,
you're back in the stone ages when you're just kind of have to drive this
yourself.
It's so weird.
So,
so you,
you do your email while you're driving,
you're not even paying attention to the machine and make sure that doesn't hit
some homeless lady who steps out off the median.
Uh,
yeah.
Like one thing that did happen yeah.
With the over a car.
Um,
yeah.
I mean I think this,
things like this will come up more rapidly than people think and I think people
will be very,
very quickly that we'll use
what aren't you doing?
What you're supposed to like look at the road,
right?
Not supposed to be staring down at your laptop.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just erase everything I said for the past minute or to,
have you ever seen the video of the guy that's falling asleep in San Francisco
traffic?
No.
He's completely asleep.
He's behind the wheel of the tussle like this and the cars like slowing and
going with the pace of traffic.
It's really fascinating because this happens so quickly.
I remember a buddy of mine got a Tesla a couple of years ago and he's like,
dude,
I let my hands off the wheel on the highway on like really like that's happening
already.
But it's not just happening like people plug into their navigate here.
This guy look at him.
This guy is stone dead asleep in his Tesla in bumper to bumper San Francisco
traffic and the car is performing flawlessly
sad.
This Dutch guy and actually just went to the back of his like on the back seat
and started changing his clothes and oh God.
Yeah.
And then apparently they did and now included the safety feature that you kind
of have to touch the wheel every minute.
Oh,
that's a new thing.
Yeah.
Bmw I believe has a similar system,
but you have to have your hand on the wheel at all times.
Yeah.
It's pretty better until it's flawless.
Yes.
Yeah.
I would imagine.
People probably do an all kinds of freaky shit in their cars while this thing is
on autopilot.
It's really not what I know.
Yeah.
It's quite amazing how,
I mean,
there was,
you were just about to show a video of Tesla autopilot crash compilations.
They,
it's saving people from crashes is what it's,
Oh,
oh,
I'm sure it does.
What's unbelievable is how few crashes there are and they said they've been two
fatalities so far.
Okay.
How many fatalities per capita versus non,
uh,
autopilot cars?
I mean,
I would imagine it's far less.
Yeah.
Obviously these cars are also just safer in general.
So,
uh,
they're not,
they're much safer then at an,
uh,
1990s Toyota Corolla or something.
So in terms of the way the construction,
yeah,
just safer when they crashed.
So I dunno how they compared the sisters statistics,
but,
um,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm very impressed too.
It was fun trying it out.
Yeah,
I'm impressed and I'm very hopeful.
The only,
my only concern I had,
my friend Matt Farah was on last week,
and he's a car expert and they've actually started an organization to save human
driving there.
They're literally going to be like lobbyists to to stop.
It doesn't get Ben,
right?
Yeah.
Well that's the concern is that one day they're going to say,
you cannot drive your own car,
and they're really worried that,
what was the name of his organization?
Do you remember?
Okay,
so,
but the,
the,
you know,
they're very serious.
He's like,
it's going to happen quicker than you think you're going.
It's going to be very difficult to drive your own car and then it's going to be
illegal.
Yeah.
Maybe they should keep areas like the highway one or things like that.
It's just something,
some freaky road where people can get crazy and looking at,
hey man,
I'm steering.
I'm hitting my own brakes.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I mean,
again,
these are just things that it's most likely inevitable.
I mean,
this,
this technology,
the way it's progressing,
it's going to be safer.
It's going to be healthier,
lower emissions,
all these variables that are going to come into play where people are gonna say
no,
there's just,
there's the benefit of driving your own car is not worth a detriment to society.
Yeah.
And next to that,
uh,
just if you think about the,
the normal rate of converting the entire car fleet to electric,
it would be around 20 years because that's sort of how long cars last.
And you only produce a few hundred million cars a year and there's billions of
cars.
So,
um,
so yeah,
if you don't want that to take 20 years,
well I think autonomy then really has to come into play because if you have
autonomous cars,
you need much less cars out there,
then you would,
if you would have to drive themselves,
because obviously cars are just driving maybe 3% of their time,
uh,
the time there,
they're just being parked so they can drive themselves.
I think the utilization of the number of cars would be much higher.
And,
um,
I think that the whole transition to electric cars would happen much faster.
So human driving association.
A human driving association is what it is here.
It pull it,
pull it back up again so you can look at it.
Yeah.
The war on driving is here.
A little paranoid.
Yeah,
they're a little paranoid,
but you've got to remember Matt Farah is an automotive journalists,
so his livelihood depends on talking about cars and he's a real legitimate car.
Nut.
What does this wrong answer?
Troy?
What does that pick?
The electric car.
Oh,
you clicked.
It says wrong answer.
You go there,
it takes you to their shop.
Well,
why is this a shame?
Oh,
I get it though.
It's just a joke.
But why would it be the wrong answer?
It's just an an answer.
Yeah.
Do you drive?
I do.
You do?
You drive an electric car.
A regular car.
Actually,
I don't have a car.
I don't know.
In Holland you don't read any cars?
You just have a,
I have a bike
can phrasing.
Yeah,
you have a coat.
He just wrote a coat on and just drive.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
Hardcore.
Listen,
I'm a big fan of Holland because I kickbox.
So you guys have some of the greatest kickboxers of all times.
Yeah.
Came from this one small place.
It's very unusual.